other people I've been helped throughout
my life I mean I've gone through some
hurdles that is true but I've also
encountered human beings who've been so
kind to me who've given me the gift of
knowledge who shared their homes with me
who shared their lives in a lot of
friendship with me that has inspired me
to give something back in my own way by
having the privilege of going to school
and to university I learned that such
things as changing the mindset of
millions and billions of people that's
not something that comes in a day it's a
long process it's just incremental
contributions from individuals within
that system and that has inspired me to
know that I can do that and there are
the dangers and the perils but then
people for instance living in the Arab
Islamic world today or Christians who
lived when the church was all-powerful
in Italy and France and that these
people were working and risking their
lives and the parable for them was much
greater than mine with my bodyguards in
and so on has also inspired me to go on
and to know that I have to be careful I
have to live and lead my life properly
but I can also give make that little
contribution that I'm making now many
people stand out there's my father in
his own way but there's also my mother
who's because of the woman she isn't
being stubborn and sticking to her
traditions and values has taught me that
being that frigid him that inflexible is
not the way to go so she's been an
example to me in a way that I knew when
I was 20 21 22 I don't want to leave my
mom's life there was a math teacher an
English teacher but I came to Holland
they have lives this woman who just
offered her help and said I'll teach you
the language and after that she was
answering all my questions and really I
become because I wasn't in the life that
I was meant to lead I was never meant to
be
self-reliant when I came to Holland yoga
this woman and other people that taught
me to be self-reliant you know to read
time to take care of my financial budget
which I had still haven't quite mastered
but that aside and then of course the
books from Spinoza to Papa and mail and
Hayek and marriage and Wollstonecraft
and the feminist movements in Europe
then the pillars of that but even coming
to America now my boss Chris Smith in
his way of leadership I mean they're
individuals all the time who inspire me
and help me in